so in terms of uh you know getting ready
for this coming season and and having
now this mojo of the second emmy in a
row
uh you know what what does that mean to
you at this point and what does that
mean now sort of your excitement level
and getting back to uh playing once
again with your co-stars and getting
back to work well it's you know when you
get the second season it it's almost
kind of
it's such a compliment and it means that
the first season wasn't just a happy
accident
and so you can kind of just relax a
little and just kind of enjoy it and
enjoy the ride and
again like i said out there
i i was blown away by the episodes that
the writers came up with for season two
because season two is a real
test and they
aced it big time it almost felt like
they wrapped the show up at the end of
season two what were your thoughts on
that and sort of okay where do we go
from here well i knew that they they
weren't oh i think hannah was a little
nervous when she read the script
um
but
i didn't really ask them what they had
in mind and i know there will have been
a little bit of time
passage before season three starts i'm
not sure if i'm supposed to say that
but um
we welcome we welcome scoop
[Laughter]
well congratulations thank you thank you
very much
over here
liz with today's show hi
season two was just taking it to another
level uh was there a specific scene that
you really felt was your biggest one
this season that earned you that award
that earned me this award um
i don't know i would say it i i it was
maybe a combination between um the the
the
we're being invaded
the uh cruise episode
and maybe episode six which was called
the click
when she's doing i just i love it when i
get to actually do stand-up in the show
for for an audience
where she suddenly changes kind of her
approach
and the audience really responds and you
just see this kind of this
pleasure and surprise that she has
in finding that
she can be the butt of the joke in a way
that's
that's good
and um
i don't know gus there was just so many
i'd say
one of those two i mean the cruise
episode was so much fun i just
i just said oh gene just you know you
got to dance you got to sing just go out
there and make a fool of yourself
and it was great fun you know and ending
up on that little
coast guard boat with with uh hannah was
i thought one of the funniest things
that they'd ever written
so i just thought it was the best
but thanks for the question
our final question comes virtually from
bj with the hollywood moment
hi gene hi
congratulations thank you not a happy
accident tonight
you are receiving this second emmy four
packs thank you
[Music]
is healing
on camera as well as off camera what do
you think all of your loved ones and
your friends that are angels above
looking down and supporting tonight this
[Music]
what do i think about that
i mean i've i've
i've got so much love in my life and and
incredibly supportive friends and
incredibly supportive um children and
two little brothers and
um
i'm grateful for all of it and i
i wish i wish of course my parents could
have seen some of
all of this you know lately and
you know and and my sister i lost my
sister
several years ago like 12 years ago
and she uh
she not only would have been my rock
this last year and a half she would have
been
my biggest cheerleader you know she just
she never begrudged one second of my
success she just thought it was the
greatest and
i'm
in all of that i'm just
incredibly
incredibly lucky
you